jean les coulisses d'une émission et se
rend compte au moins un amour un amour
tout d'un coup couchent ensemble on
retrouve leurs enfants sur la télévision
aujourd'hui ça concerne quelqu'un cette
équipe ça concerne thierry moreau à pied
apparemment tête dans les coulisses des
[ __ ] ne vais pas s'est amourachée de
francis cabrel et on a retrouvé leurs
enfants sur la télévision et devinez
quoi
et les chanteurs comme papa
c
[Applaudissements]
car là bas
le trac rôle assez saisissant à nommer
les fellaghas ses mémoires sous les noms
si vous voulez vous avez enfin petit qui
fait un peu cheap show est ce qu'il est
un peu partout c'est le chanteur facile
à gérer mais bien pour la femme les
rôles
un problème
thierry mauron et consiste à la personne